hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the right it
goes Ross you know about halfway to the
chapter that you're working on says the
moral convictions of thoughtful and
well-educated people are the data of
ethics the data means you know sort of
starting points that we use to make
sense out of things and what did we know
what does he mean well think about when
you handle data in other you know other
circumstances other fields other
disciplines the dad is what you're
observing right that's what it means
literally data that which is given comes
from the Latin word for forgiving and
it's what is given to you when you go
out to gather data you're looking for
what's going on now what would that be
immoral life what is the data of moral
life you guys have been gathering it for
a long time whether you realized it or
not every time that you know you got
into some sort of situation where it
could go this way or it could go this
way
ask yourself what's the right thing to
do and you consulted your feelings about
it or some principles about it maybe you
actually did the wrong thing and then
you realize it was the wrong thing later
bed of your attitude what's happening to
me a lot of times still does every once
in a while what else adults telling you
things along the way knocked it off you
know when they say knock that off and
you feel that kind of a twinge or you
know depending on how they phrased it to
you know what else a bit what a lot of
it maybe you actually like you know got
out of them got out of the room so you
didn't get hit or anything like that you
were actually learning about moral life
now you might be miss learning things
right if your parents Kathy might makes
right philosophy whatever I say goes you
know you're basically just here to
satisfy my wins and needs because I'm
the powerful one and you're not you know
in power they probably screwed you up
all right you seen kids like that you
know adults like that still no anything
else like this have these days where you
look at them Excel out my first a
terrible upbringing somebody really
screwed that get up on the other hand
you guys recognize this I think you
would go to other people's houses and
visit did you ever compare them with
your own yeah how did it turn out
favorably unfavorably did you feel that
your you know your household was really
squared away and other people they were
getting it wrong where sometimes you say
and I kind of like the way things go
over there a bit better than the way
things go here and it's not just because
you know they got candy or got to play
games or things like the other people
talk nice to each other you know in the
AL or things like that it was probably
in part at least at some points you're
like that data actually like you know
helps out with with homework what's
wrong with mine you know shouldn't he be
helping me out with that or taking an
interest in it or you know think
whatever else you like you know that mom
when she has to divide up good things
between us kids she doesn't play
favorites as a matter of fact she even
gives me an equal she had with him on
just a guest that would be actually
learning about moral life in roxas where
ross is beginning he thinks that the way
in which we become to know these things
is not so much by moral theories which
is what you guys been studying rightful
of course the semester it's more by
looking at the way in which we actually
do think and feel and act not just you
know everybody because there's some
people who are screwed up and you don't
want to consult them right do you think
of anybody off hand who would make a
terrible moral instructor you know maybe
somebody in the news recently maybe they
come to mind
you guys watch TV right or stuff on the
internet at least anything going on that
last 10 years that you can say wow that
person should not be in charge of kids
in our moral double friend who would you
would you pick for the prize for that
yeah that's key yeah yeah I guess
there'd be a glaring instance right and
actually he was in charge of kids that's
part of what made it so problematic and
he'd be like fool people for years and
years and years that's why people felt
betrayed and some people actually felt
the data duty to defend the guy and then
after a while once that you know more
and more information started coming out
then they starting again yeah maybe I
shouldn't defend this guy maybe I should
actually be criticizing him yeah I mean
if you imagine growing up in a household
where not only that's where the thing
was going on but it was being presented
as if it was the norm the way things
ought to be how screwed up with that
make you so you wouldn't actually want
to consult that person's moral
intuitions you know a thoughtful and
well educated people so it's not just
any you know Joe Blow on the street it's
going to be people who have you know
actually given some thoughts you look to
people whose lives seem very clearly
well squared away you know Ross is
willing to say you can't actually know
who is and who isn't til you scratch the
surface when you look at those people
and then you see where they are and what
they have to have to think about these
sort of things we'll come back to that
more I want to touch on some of the
other theories that he talks about and
he says well they're not doing this so
you talks about egoism and it talks
about hedonism and militarism and things
that each one of these there's something
wrong with a spirit it doesn't jive with
the way in which we actually think about
what we ought to do our duties right and
so you know as we go through this think
about whether this makes sense for you
what does the egoism say you ought to do
what are your what are your duties as an
equalist yourself interest yeah what is
yourself yeah very good so you should
consult your own self-interest or
benefit and pay attention that and say
everybody else's can forget about that
and do whatever it takes to say maximize
your satisfaction of your interests and
so he says well you know that can't be
right I mean people do behave that way
right you know some people who act that
way and we actually know some people who
talk that way interestingly sometimes
people who talk that way you watch their
lives and you find out actually they're
not Equalists they're they're helping
people out on the side which they
shouldn't be doing you know even when it
doesn't benefit them and he says uh you
know the theory comes to grief over the
fact that stares us in a fan that it
stares us in the face a great part of
duty great part of what we feel obliged
to do what we sense ourselves to have an
obligation to do consists of observance
of the rights and a further into the
interests of others now that could be
compatible with being any ghosts right
you can be an AOS you want to be nice to
people so they're nice to you but then
it says whatever the cost to ourselves
maybe so when we feel ourselves under an
obligation that's how you can tell
people who actually
sense of obligation those who don't
people who have a sense of obligation
think that whatever the cost is to them
if they have an obligation to another
person they're supposed to do that they
may not fulfill it but they they at
least have a sense that hey that's what
I want to be doing so if egoism doesn't
really work it doesn't really fit the
way in which we we tend to think about
things in the real world even though
there are a lot of people who act like
egoists they often time to recognize
that they're doing the wrong thing
that's why they try to hide their
actions that's why they try to argue
that they're actually good for everybody
else right heel ism in utility anism his
criticisms of these have to do with the
issue of pleasure is pleasure the only
good thing so you don't think back to
when we were talking about hedonism for
I think for some of you you had that aha
moment rusev yeah this makes sense now I
finally get everything really is about
pleasure and pain some of you said yeah
but what about this what about this this
doesn't seem to be reducible times the
pleasure of me and Ross says you know
once we want to understand pleasure
really really attenuated sense you know
where it almost doesn't mean anything is
pleasure really the only good that we
ought to be thinking about the only
thing that we we seek were other other
things that we value yeah he talks about
two things well then he spikes but
another one in another chapter and he
leaves out something that you guys have
brought up a lot relationships our
relationships just about pleasure for
you where you see a value in at least
some of your relationships that goes
beyond and pleasure that you have in it
what do you think what would you say do
you do as soon as somebody stops being
pleasurable or likely to be pleasurable
at the future you cut them off is that
how you guys behave
I doubt it there may be a few people who
you said this person is a pain literally
a pain and i'm not going to hang around
to them anymore well those people are
probably not that close to you okay who
are people that are close to you that
are sometimes a pain and maybe at this
point you're you don't necessarily
derive a lot pleasure from but you feel
yourself you feel that your relationship
that's worth something hopefully not
your boyfriend or girlfriend or husband
or wife because you know that would kind
that would be pretty awful but that
could happen I mean if you make a
commitment to somebody you say for
better for worse and then things turn
out for worse they get you know horribly
maimed and can't really do much with you
and your life with them is mostly just
taking care of that which is not a lot
of fun you'd still say it's important to
do that would you or if you're looking
at somebody else in that situation of
data which was a see you later no longer
pleasurable for me you would say there's
something wrong action who in your life
currently do you find to be kind of a
pain and maybe wish things were
different but they're not and you don't
even know if they're going to be in the
future but yet you feel that your
relationships or something family
which family members the crazy cousin
who you only see once a year probably
huh who then yeah I need a lot of people
find their parents to be a pain but they
say hey this is my mom is my dad I you
know this is this worth something you
know mckean this perspective that
doesn't make sense maybe brothers and
sisters if you have a screw-up brother
sister still your brother sister okay
sometimes even still log in the land was
in a one-foot sort of things they do and
you can think about other cases like
this as well utilitarianism is cannabis
strange bird because it's saying you
know everybody's pleasures have to be
looked at equally and then that's kind
of good because it gets us away from you
know straight out of egoism he says but
again is that all there is is pleasure
in addition to relationships which ross
doesn't actually talk about it this
thing he says moral cultivation what he
calls virtue you know character that's
worth something to you as know isn't
your character valuable tier isn't the
character of your friends valuable to
you don't you have some people who
you're friends with because they're
there you know I don't know if the
female equivalent would be for this we
think about that what's a female
equivalent of a stand-up guy you know
you guys all know that that phrase right
a stand-up guy that somebody was loyal
who you can count on who actually has
good character you can rely on them to
do the right thing you can trust your
family with them that's valuable right
that's not just about pleasure what else
intellectual development what you guys
are engaged now you know I granted a lot
of the this class is for you
means to them at graduation we've talked
about this many times but some of those
stuff that you guys are studying when
you have that moment where it clicks you
say yeah now this makes sense and I know
this from a lot of your papers that's
intellectual development you've acquired
something you are at a higher level than
you were before and is that always
pleasant what if you think studying
pleasant how many of you like studying
battery one study I used to I can't wash
the taste credit after a while I you
know I do enjoy you know doing
philosophy but I don't necessarily sit
down like sitting down and making myself
ok now I have to read this and focus on
this but it pays off doesn't it right
you have something that's that's yours
that you can hold on so these don't
really work he talks about a GP works
theory but I'm going to skip over this
well I'll then talked about how much
India and you would say well you know
Ross is a demonologist concert
demonologists they should be on the same
page right and they should be a complete
agreement what's the problem with Khan
well when he's talking about duty he
tries to reduce everything to one
principle he's got this thing called the
categorical categorical imperative which
were a little gap near future and cut
thinks that we're generally you know
trying to reduce everything to what he
calls perfect duties do
that are completely obligatory upon us
and we can distinguish those from
imperfect duties which you know are
there not optional but but they don't
have the same sort of prior or into them
so for example comets say you should
never tell the lie never ever ever ever
ever and we'll see why we look at condom
the categorical imperative but are there
situations in which you probably ought
to tell a lie many utilitarians would
say yeah does we'll get you know what
benefits the largest amount of people if
the killer is you know at the door the
nursery and says I want to kill some
babies and you know you could tell them
hey maternity ward is on the other side
of the hospital and that will give you
enough time to call security is that a
good mind at all what do you guys think
yes I tell it and utilitarian to tell it
to count would say no even though it's
going to bring about bad consequences
you still should lie Ross would say you
got to look at what your actual duties
are some duties in particular cases are
more stringent than other duties it's
not so simple as having one principle by
which we can derive everything so how do
we actually get a sense of what our
duties are we ought to do he says when a
plain man fulfills a promise because he
thinks he ought to seems clear that he
does so with no thought of its total
consequences most people were there you
know carrying out moral reasoning do
they they actually sit down and say now
how would every single stakeholder be
affected by this they fill out a
worksheet similar to the one that I gave
you for utilitarian ism now we might do
something a little bit like that in some
circumstances do we consult the
categorical imperative do we think to
ourselves am i acting
28 the maximum of my action can be made
into a universal law of nature that I
can well probably yeah right there's
something more basic than that but
because of the fact that it's more basic
it ends up being able to help rural
istic their end up being hungry but that
works see that word what do you think
you oughta Becca not plural means more
than one there's going to be more than
one mode of obligation more than one
kind of thing that we ought to do and so
Ross is going to call these prima
fashion and this is his main
contribution to moral theory the way
that you know people look at us today it
was a lot more in this book but this is
probably the most important notion that
he puts on the table this is the one
that I think that a lot of you can
relate to quite well I know that you
can't because you're like other students
right now their students tend to get
this as well in part because it makes
good sense because he's focusing on our
ordinary moral consumptions one of the
other criticisms that Ross yeah the
qualities that I want to stop not
necessarily heroism but of
utilitarianism concha deontology is the
fact that duties are
these are personal you have duties not
just because you're a human being and
all human beings have duties you know a
certain sort but because you're that guy
you're the apple your you know your
father's daughter you're your mother's
son down up down the one right you guys
have duties to each other as classmates
that didn't exist before you sat down in
this classroom ten weeks ago like he
says these theories tend to unduly
simplify our relations to our fellows
they say in effect the only morally
significant relation in which neighbor
stand to me is you know being that
fisheries or you know other ways of
putting it in this relation of being a
possible beneficiary of my action that's
important but what else he says other
human beings stand to me in the relation
of promisee to promise her people that
you make promises to of credit or debit
of wife to husband a child's apparent a
friend friend a fellow countryman fellow
countryman and alike and each of these
relations he says is the foundation of a
prima facie duty which is more or less
incumbent upon me according to the
circumstances of the case so the fact
that you exist in this fabric of
concrete relationships that are part of
who you are right you're so and so's
daughter and she's not and she's
somebody else's daughter and you know
you guys could be connected with each
other you study partners or something
like that that would create other
obligations friends to become friends I
suppose your families could be connected
by marriage and some someone's fashion
but you're never going to the same
parents right you're never going to have
the same duties to the same people you
can compare your duties to each other
you know I feel
a good son because you know I look at
him and he's done so much more for his
parents that I have things I should have
been doing but those are still his
parents that's his duty that's his
relationship to them mine is to my know
right yeah duties are intensely personal
like this